in the circle below central angle G Oh H
so central angle G Oh H has a measure of
three-halves radians what is the length
of Arc gh so let's define some variables
that'll help us manipulate them a little
bit easier so we're a central angle G o
H that's G o H it's this angle right
over here let's call that theta so let's
say that theta is equal to the measure
measure of G Oh H of angle of angle G Oh
H now they're asking us what's the
length of gh arc gh well arc gh is this
right over here and let's call that s so
let's let s be equal to the length the
length of arc arc gh and they also give
us the radius is 6 centimeters for this
circle but let's just call that R for
now so the radius is equal to 6
centimeters so the first thing that we
should think about when we're dealing
with arc lengths in radians is how do
how does how do angles measured in
radians relate to arc length in
particular how does an angle measured in
radians relate to the length of the arc
that subtends that angle and in this
case the length this arc right over here
arc GH sub tens angle theta sub tens
central angle Geo H so what's the
relationship well the definition of
Radian measure says that an angle
measured in radians is the ratio between
the length of arc that subtends that
angle so s and the radius of the circle
and the radius of the circle if this was
a unit circle then it would just
literally be equal to that arc length if
it's not a rate unit circle or I guess
in all cases unit circle or not it's the
ratio between the length of the arc that
subtends the angle and and the radius
now given this this
this definition really of what a Radian
is let's see what we know and what we
don't know and we can we can manipulate
this however we see fit we could
multiply you could see this written as
if you multiply both sides of this by R
if you multiply both sides of this by r
you get R theta is equal to s or another
way of writing it is you could get s is
equal to R times theta s is equal to R s
is equal to R theta and we could have
solved this equation or this equation
but for this problem this one's actually
going to be a little bit useful because
this is the unknown the length of G H we
want to know we want to know what this
is this is the unknown that they're
asking for and this explicitly solves
for the unknown so this essentially
solved it for us so what else do we know
well we know the radius we know the
radius is 6 centimeters we multiply that
times the angle in radians which is
three-halves radians and we are left
with so s is equal to 6 centimeters
times three-halves and so we are left
with this is going to be equal to 6
times 3 is 18 divided by 2 is 9 it's
going to be equal to 9 centimeters and
we are we are done